and this is where your eyes just start
to water and you promptly flip the table
and go home okay they ask you to prove
this monster of a result let me just
write it down okay
this is what they want is that the
deceit cubed plus one equals take a deep
breath this guy well I'll just write
this down now they're quick the first
secondary side tangent how do people
come up with these things because I just
make is I just have a look at they are
like pod D for instance the result would
just prove there's a pot which we will
also prove and I'll give you it's just a
number by the way um how do you like
cosplay online bio nine what is primal
90 degrees if 20 degrees 20 degrees what
do we know about the exact I was 20
degrees it's up almost nothing right
it's not 30 45 60 is not something nice
and neat okay and then they somehow pull
a rabbit out of a hat and get D and then
get F right out of something which
should be an irrational disaster I can't
like get my sense of the word okay now
the fact that they can pull out so much
information and semi relationships out
of so little like what have they done
then they just said oh nice roots of
unity let's just start digging and see
where we go right I think it's very
profound these kinds of results can get
replicated for all different kinds of
answers and it's part of how it's part
of how calculators in order how did they
know what's I'm 23 degrees
okay you're part of it come from all of
these results okay let's have a go and
the first thing I notice is again when
you are given a results accrue look
carefully at what you've been given and
think about what pieces of this connect
to what you've already done
okay example have a look at the
arguments have a look at the arguments
just by 9 for pie-o-my 8 pile of 9 is
this likely to be in connection to the
previous part no I would actually
suggest no I think D gets skipped over
okay when you look at D D is the part
which has gotten rid of the 8 pi 9 right
and now it's reappeared in 8 I think he
actually has more to do with C and its
earlier parts because the a pile of 9 is
there that haven't illuminated we get to
F you can see the a pile of nines ignore
it so it looks like they'll use it again
but at least on a I'm going to draw most
of my crews from Part C and earlier okay
all right he's the second thing have a
look you've got this you've got this I
notice but essentially I'm just taking a
polynomial to the degree six and I'm
just replicating it with another
polynomial of degree six okay so how do
I get from here to here do you agree
that this is just a fancy and read
factorized form of this do you agree
with that that's a weird factorized form
of this okay factorizing factorizing is
a hard problem when you're dealing with
you know high degree polynomials and
that kind of thing right we know how to
do with small degree okay we know that I
could write something like this in this
form okay now keep in mind the reason I
know this can be written like this is
because I know it's a quadratic which is
how many roots has two and so I'm going
to have two linear factors do you agree
with that now there are too many factors
here this is a polynomial of degree 6
how many linear factors will it have
it will have six and because of the
fundamental theorem of algebra I know
exactly what those six linear factors
will be in fact about ten minutes ago I
drew them okay so here's what I'm gonna
say look this thing I should be able to
break it up into one two three four five
six parts I noticed there are only three
here right we'll get to three in a
second one of the six parts I named the
six pots earlier didn't I I named those
solutions and solutions like minus 2 and
minus 3
give me factors minus 2 minus 4 your
solutions so X plus 2 X 4 8 are factored
to agree with that
so therefore the factors of this will be
sorry this is then take away what did I
call my first solely show you I called
is that what because it was the first to
issue right and then the next one is
gonna be easy to and then the next one
will be then three and so on all the way
okay now I'm gonna get from the
conjugate in a second
I just want to get this down because
this is a conceptual leap right we are
this to the fundamental theorem of
algebra and the fact that I know I can
write a linear factorization of every
polynomial if you let me work in complex
numbers right you know we can't always
do this if you're only in real numbers
for instance wait b squared minus 4ac
plus if this not given to you write the
discriminant of this guy is 9 take away
20 negative 11 you cannot do a linear
factorization of this in the real
numbers right you're stuck but if you
give me complex numbers I can write a
linear factorization like so by it'll be
weird but it'll exist okay and that's
what this is
what this is okay now we said a moment
ago we've got three factors here they're
not veneer back to zero
they are quadratic factors you notice
that so that kind of implies I want to
pair up some of these factors okay
what's a natural way to pair some of
these factors you use the conjugates
okay so I'm gonna go is there takeaway
said one and I'm going to pair it we
said takeaways at four which is really
Zed take away the conjugate is at one I
was on defined right yeah do that okay
then you've got this code you get this
they are these same factors I've just
rewritten the conjugates appropriately
and I have reordered them to make the
conjugate pairs obvious okay okay now
we're ready to go